بشاحنه وخيام قليله وكميات محدوده من
المستلزمات الطبيه استنفر متطوعون وانشاوا
عيادات متنقله في جنديرس في حلب شمال
سوريا حلول سريعه يجرب متطوعون من خلالها
تخفيف اعباء المتضررين من كارثه الزلزال
ام المشاكل انه صار فقد للكوادر الطبيه
بسبب الزلزال فكثير من الكوادر او جزء من
الكوادر طبيه في المنطقه ووفته الماليه
نتيجه الزلزال وقسم اخر من الكوادر الطبيه
فقد اهاليه والمقربين
هنا حيث العيون تحكي كيف تنهش تداعيات
الزلزال من نجوا منه او اصيبوا والذي
نطفوا عددهم قدره الاطقم الطبيه على
مواجهتها الحلول مطلوبه سريعا فالحالات
مؤلمه هذا ما يقوله المتطوعون فهناك اشخاص
مهددون ببدر اجزاء من اجسادهم وبحاجه ماسه
لعمليات جراحيه واخرون بحاجه الى غرف
عنايه مركزه ومجهزه
والله اولادي كلهم مرضان يفوتوا
وبخلاف المصابين هناك من فرضت كارثه
الزلزال نسيانهم وهم من اصحاب الامراض
المزمنه فمرضى الكلى يحتاجون الى مستلزمات
طبيه لغسيل كلاهم المتعبه وفي حال طال
غيابها ربما يصبح ضحايا تضاف الارقام قتل
الزلزال
خلال عشر سنوات مضت تعرضت المشافي شمالي
سوريا لخسائر كبيره وبحسب لجنه الانقاذ
الدوليه فان نحو 70% من العاملين في
القطاع الصحي غادروا المنطقه وباتت النسبه
طبيبا واحدا لكل عشره الاف نسمه حنان
المصري العربيه